what would you think if cristina
fernandez returned to control and
dominate argentina could something like
this ever happen
[Applause]
[Music]
give us lost april 2019 a survey caused
a political earthquake in argentina an
earthquake that also had significant
economic consequences you see the
consultancy firm insomnia a company that
actually has close ties to the
government's and has been working with
Macri for several years noted that if
the next argentinian elections reached
the second round the first round will be
held on October the 27th and November
the 24th for the second rounds if that
happens Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner
hypothetical candidacy would win over
the current president Mauricio Macri
[Music]
right now poor economic performance is
causing support for president Macri to
plummet inflation is extremely high
tariff increases and the sense that
nothing has really changed in the
political level has caused Mauricio
macri's popularity to drop like a rock
[Music]
but just a second on May the 18th the
second political earthquake shook
Argentina for the first time in history
of vice presidential candidate named her
choice for president oh boy a cameo vice
would Iike men taken when gobierno and
some Frank Paredes para cambiar face as
if I do well you go you don't know you
niveau an associate our Cristina
Fernandez made her decision do you stand
for election public but not as number
one as the two vice presidential
candidates former argentine president
critters seeks return to power as vice
president yeah that correctly in the end
the cash nearest candidate will be
alberta fernandez néstor Kirchner's
chief of staff he also held that post in
Christina's government for one year
I've asked Alberto Fernandez to present
the formula that we will run together he
as the presidential candidate and I as
vice president to participate in the
upcoming primary open simultaneous and
mandatory elections Cristina Fernandez
de Kirchner face do with this leadership
scenario at least three questions
surface the first is easy one earth did
Kirchner decide to do this Super Saver
era
eNOS objetivos nadie puede ser la cosa
dos três anos well let's just say that
the answer has a lot to do with their
currently good popularity as we've seen
for the first time since 2015 several
polls place Kirchner as the winner for
not only the first rounds but also the
second eat it fast so the experiment
goes amiga company receipt concern
educating and I wound up a lot of
seizures and plus a fee economy okay
Marino know why not
[Music]
now hold on just a second the same
forecasts also indicated a high number
of undecided votes and folks this was
very clear to election experts the fear
of Kirchner's return once it's election
time could shift many votes back to the
current ruling party however with this
decision two things happen on the one
hand fear of the former president is
somewhat diluted she's no longer
presidential candidate and on the other
the new duo could reach voters that
Kirchner would have never reached alone
[Music]
allow me to explain
Alberto Fernandes candidacy puts
regeneration ISM on the table his
discourse is more moderate and as the
idea that the new duo would apply
different policies to those implemented
by Christina in the past this is
essential to achieve victory because of
course if you want to win the elections
you can't just count on your stores you
have to convince new voters who are also
taking care not to mobilize your rivals
vote as vice president christina
contributes all her electoral strength
without causing excessive fear so based
on this scenario the former president's
decisions multiply her options of
returning to power and that's what she
cares about the most not just because
she likes power but because she needs to
maintain the rights that go with being a
high-level politician in order to
survive
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner needed to
participate in the elections due to a
legal situation which we already have
discussed here on visual politic the
ex-president has ten prosecutions and
five preventive detention requests you
see the only reason she isn't already in
jail is because she still has her
senator privileges for Senate which is
dominated by para nests is simply not
withdrawn them so the first question why
she decided to run as vice president as
has already been answered the second
question is can this pairing really win
the elections and I mean are we really
being serious here the previous
government's results before not exactly
brilliant and there was a lot of
corruption the steerer Krishnas
processing in notebooks scandal extended
judge cloudy open a deal considered her
a co-author of five other acts of
bribery and raised the embargo against
her 218 million pesos
well yeah at least that's what the voter
intentions studies save surveys place
Kouchner ahead with an advantage of nine
point five and four in two different
surveys we can also find surveys even
more important ones which put Macri in
the lead but by an increasingly smaller
margin and of course now with the new
formula many of the fears of Kirchner
ISM have diluted particularly because
Alberto Fernandez himself was very
critical of the form of residents she
even said that Germany was worse than us
in terms of poverty maintained that the
stocks didn't exist and that inflation
didn't matter in the end that's denial a
stubborn sometimes
absurd denial Alberto Fernandez 2015
that is how overnight the Kirchner
created formula can be seen as a sign of
change something like hey we learned our
mistakes but our intentions they were
always good and now we've got it figured
out and the important thing isn't a
person's job title but the projects
pretty incredible right
now let's be clear you can't really say
that this is a surprising or an
exceptional scenario not at all
it's part of a fairly predictable trend
actually Macri has gone from leading in
the polls in January to drawing with
Christina in March and then lagging
behind her in April as incredible as it
may seem according to the polls
Christina's support hasn't stopped
rising the former presidents has gone
from being a headache Peron ism which
wanted to revamp its image to becoming
its best wild cards a chance of
recovering the governments of the
Republic at the moment it seems like the
evolution of the economy will be the
decisive factor here if things weren't
so bad perhaps even Macri could get
enough support from undecided voters do
remain in the Casa Rosada the problem as
things stand breathing the economic
situation in the short-term seems quite
complicated and that that is Kirchner's
best card right now one more slip and
Macri is sent to the bench you see the
Argentine economy is going through a
very very fragile time inflation in
March was four point seven percent
that's the rate for one month not one
year 2019 could close with a 35 to 50
percent inflation rate the peso p-- just
keeps falling against the dollar stocks
of not doing well and the country's risk
is now over a thousand points and the
country is still in recession
folks that race between mockery and
Kirchner's hypothetical can disease has
become a race to be the least bad in the
eyes of public opinion and now this
isn't just our criticism this is just
simple fact
[Music]
both Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner and
Mauricio Macri are reaping very negative
evaluations from the Argentinians in the
case of the current president according
to surveys up to 84 percent of
Argentinians have a negative opinion
about him on the other hand though it
may seem incredible given all the
scandals the former presidents data are
actually somewhat better but not that
much in our case the negative opinion
score is 76 percent but now with the
arrival of our Berta Fernanda things are
different the new candidates is less
tainted than the former presidents
Ginobili with Australian where the
single cashier from latina Brazilian
territory consider cosas para C&F taught
Maharaja Tina so you know Alberto
Fernandez in a figure income is
potential parallel economy para la vida
hinge so the third and most important
question based on what we've seen would
be or consequences with the victory of a
birthday Fernandez and Cristina
Fernandez de Kirchner have and some more
kind of public policies would they bet
[Music]
well it turns out we don't even have to
wait until October to start answering
you see the mere fact the CashNet became
a favorite in the polls has already made
all international investors very very
nervous and really perhaps we should be
just saying that it's made them even
more nervous than they already were and
that has translated into the new drop of
the peso against the dollar this may
also have fuelled the idea of this new
and surprising formula so why so much
nervousness it was assumed that
Christina's return to power would mean a
return to these same ultra
interventionalist policies and tons of
public spending as in the previous stage
okay so Macri he didn't lead any great
change either but if Christina returned
any possibility of Argentina changing
and don't tell me it doesn't need to
change we simply go out of the window
[Music]
the simple facts the Kirchner took the
lead in the polls fueled investors fear
of a new and upcoming Argentine default
and that makes things even worse to such
an extent that even some analysts such
as Carlos Malamud have warns of a
forthcoming exchange run that is the
peso will sink even more because
everyone will want to get rid of the
currency he thinks this is gonna happen
if Kirchner ISM continues to improve its
chances of getting back into power in
any case regardless of whether Macri
wins or loses the elections Argentina's
current situation is complicated the
government will have to return a
whopping thirty four billion dollars in
2020 in a context of a severe economic
recession and with a peso that is
depreciating full-speed Argentina is at
a crossroads its debt in dollars is huge
accounting for almost 90 percent of the
GDP a figure that won't stop increasing
due to the pesos collapse the more the
peso Falls the greater the burden of
debt in dollars for the Argentine
economy the probability that Argentina
will not succeed in paying this debt
within one presidential term is high
yes the probability of default is high
but it isn't a fact the situation is not
yet irreversible unfortunately it seems
that almost all political leaders are
clear on this the fact that Christina
has decided to run as vice president in
Alberta Fernandez's candidacy could be a
good test after all as we've already
seen Alberta fen and death was very
critical of Cristina Fernandez
management however Argentina does need a
total change of course and to be frank
Alberta Fernanda he doesn't seem so
committed to leading that change given
his current running mate is the former
presidents and this is what leads us to
this video's main question will the new
governments be it Macri Fernandez or any
other candidate be willing to carry out
that massive change well leave your
answer in the comments below as well as
in this survey and I really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast as well they
provided the vocals in this episode but
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see in the next video
[Music]